um I got it this
time y full screen what's up it's a big
deal it's President's Day oh that's
right that means that everybody else
gets the day off so we took it upon
ourselves to continue rescuing the
president's daughter for whatever reason
Ivanka we're coming for you although
actually I played as Ivanka last time
and I did a pretty good job you just got
back so she has a couple things to give
Leon all right here let's try this let's
try this again so it says I got some
items from Ashley mhm um shop pretty
good on supplies it looks like it's been
a while since
we I think triangle oh crap you're right
I got it I got it I'm back I'm back in
the zone no no no what put it next to
the first aid it's bothering me that
like when I actually want to be
organized you don't what are you talking
about I always I have been putting my
stuff in the upper right Health items
since
I was a we so one thing uh my buddy
showed me it's like super minor but you
could line up all the weapons on the
left side so then when you pause to
switch weapons it's really quick it
doesn't matter though cuz if you pause
safe anyway this giant Mama well no cuz
I I doubt you're going to use that
anytime soon I wouldn't advise you to
use it anytime soon so what do you want
me to do with my weapons never
mind I'm confused he just saying you
line the weapons up on the left so when
you pause to switch weapons it's really
quick you don't have to go across the
whole case oh but again it's minor
because you're safe when you pause
anyway it just saves like two seconds I
see I see super I like my system I got
like I got like all my nades here I got
my golden egg which I'm not touching and
I'm never going to touch okay ever I'm
gonna make it all right cool so oh I got
another one good job
Ivanka good job
me who gets credit you or her um whoever
did a better job Hunan
nope not at all a what a touching moment
we have here how old did he say spoiled
thanks to your Interruption him why
don't you do us all a favor and leave
before the audience gets pissed off she
just got that like old man you're
nothing but an extra in
my to car it away your biggest scene is
over remember being a part of your crap
I know well then why don't you show me
what the first class script is like
banter is so ridiculous like it's it
shouldn't be no okay we're coming up on
uh a little bit of backtracking I
apologize to people but it'll be worth
it for those who know what I'm talking
about um little thing that a lot of
people play resent Evil 4 might miss but
luckily I'm
here you are I'm so lucky what am I
doing you're so Leon um pull your map up
actually I can't believe I'm telling you
to do this but pull your map up
yes like switching places I'm into the
inventory management the map map okay um
so have to jog my memory zoom out okay
so I'm supposed to going down but you
don't actually want to do that so let me
scroll up to the top left a little bit
more you want to go right
where trying to remember where this
is this okay see that red door on the
left um you want to go there this
there's a very useful item on the other
side here I don't know if you remember
but you could not get there before
because door was locked and there was an
opening up top that you needed Ashley
for now you have her so yeah should I go
this way yes okay so I'm going to the
back of this room taking you're going
back through that cage match room all
right do I need to go down here no I
don't think you can okay uh back behind
you follow me yeah you're
going they'll pay for you your death oh
you know what I should change Sous
fellow in his time I'm going to change
weapons real fast hereo oh I almost
killed that guy out of fear you can kill
him I can yeah I think it's on the
hardest difficulty he does not even come
back if you kill him got some rare
things on sale stranger what are you say
I don't even know if I have anything no
I think you did it last time oh yeah you
do you have a bunch got some stuff got
this velvet blue
is church song every time
got thank you wait for the red for can I
sell no wait for that going go in yeah
that you can can is that all stranger
okay cool thank you and then what are
you buying I don't think I need anything
what is even updated I have no idea what
are you
buying okay that's it sweet thanks dude
all right I think you're going the right
way yeah you
are is there even anything in here I've
already killed everything they they will
be back I oh really farther in maybe let
me just double check oh
oops I haven't used my map in so long I
forgot how it works okay so uh it's
probably faster to straight go little
down not up you could go either way but
down would probably be faster okay
actually come to think of it might be
less people if you go back through the
Labyrinth not through the Labyrinth but
like along the Labyrinth where's the
Labyrinth up instead of down oh well I
mean I don't mind what do you think just
I think you'll be fine fighting the guys
if you go down okay if memory serves
there will be a few more guys that like
respawn okay because just these dudes on
really yeah okay let me [__] I keep
there's that door to your left you can
go through okay are you sure yeah oh no
sorry not straight and straight got it
you're this is that room where you shot
that glass of wine on the painting wait
there it
is and then left kill
this is he just going to swing you from
there what the
[__] run
girlfriend you've been in here too just
go through that
door I can't believe they come back
that's so
cruel um I
think let's just check the map oh no I
want take a right yeah you're almost
there this is going fairly well walking
from one place to another yeah no
incidents haven't killed
anyone all right so you're going to lift
her through that window she's going to
she sh unlock the door for you
okay in that Treasure Chest how do
I okay should be something popping there
you go got it I was worrying me for a
second did I lead you here for no
reason don't look up
I think he said something doesn't he
about her I don't remember maybe not
there's so many
like oop go open that [__] wow there's a
lot here but guess what you just got a
gun it's the broken butterfly I don't
know what that is the Magnum so that's
the thing you could have bought from the
dude for I forget how much but you save
also how much thanks mhm and I got an
elegant perfume Bott I tell you to just
save the Magnum and the Magnum ammo for
the last fight okay
which is really easy actually if you do
it right
oh this has been very
good
um why does that green herb look
different is that one upside down you
see that that green oh
yes
[Music]
um so I just hold this like I don't want
to do anything with it yeah it doesn't
take up all that much eight spaces okay
see if this was my attach case I would
just have like Xanax down here
too I like your openness with your use
of
Xanax medically prescribed Xanax yeah
yes for sure um
okay
um who was
it I don't know there's been a lot more
open
conversation you talking about um Carrie
Fisher about mental illness am yeah her
uh her ear was a Prozac yeah pill which
I thought was pretty cool all right
where am I going do you want me to go
down here now back to where you just
were and then really I can't go like
this way or do you want me to go that
way oh [__] uh zoom out I think you need
to go down first cuz my my goal is to
get here for some reason so my question
is yeah you're like am I supposed to go
here and go and take this long tube you
are correct okay so I need to turn
around and go back the way I came yep
okay
wait I'm super I have no clue it's one
of these doors uh yeah I feel pretty
good about this
one yeah it is sweet wait where's
Ashley should be she's with you uh or
did you tell her to wait follow
me I guess I told her wait she
okay she might have still been in weight
mode after climbing through that window
where is she I hear her slamming open
doors where is she oh God she's H I'm
back she's the scariest thing in this
game kind of disappointed I think I
asked if someone could Photoshop Ivanka
over the health bar Ashley thing I don't
think anybody's done it yet so oh oh
like ivanka's name uh face no it's her
name down here buff Leon [__] okay wait
just avoid these dudes again you're
going through the opposite
door oh there's a flashbang right there
hold on hold on hold on you want me to
do it no there's a flashbang right on
that counter cabinet well Ashley's in
danger [__] her yeah just cat Mouse him
around the other side flashbang will be
handy in that
thing uh it stopped being worth it
really really fast actually yeah yeah
[__] it's
okay
[Music]
run
Ashley you might as well finish them off
with the hangun see if they drop
anything
[Music]
okay
stay
down [__] I shouldn't have done that so
much your health is getting pretty
high your max Health you mean in this
sense yeah like I got I got Health to
spare now
yeah it's not form any bad habits though
I mean in addition to the I can afford
them now is I feel like is what I'm
learning Al so one thing people have
been pointing out through this whole
playr and I keep forgetting to mention
is that if you're going to go to the
merch and upgrade your ammo capacity
it's best not to reload before you do
that because upgrading your ammo
capacity automatically up without using
Amo it happens like that's pretty cool
it only happens maybe like eight times
throughout the game I didn't realize but
it's worth it it'll save you like when
you have Max when you have like 16
rounds in a clip for your red nine it'll
save you a lot and my fault for forg
getting you can do that as a way to like
get a bunch of extra ammo right like
yeah I mean you save it that's pretty
good all right what am I doing um yeah
going through here are you sure mhm cuz
I could always open so you're pretty
much about to get the last piece to open
that central door which I don't think
you did yet but yeah you're going
through here
okay it's going
well just going
to
um I don't even know if you need to save
well I just saved so I'm not going to
check your map I think you can just I
mean you have to go both of these yeah
no uh go not to that yet get away from
me
ianka oh Leon be careful with your knife
no don't go this way yet oh I mean it's
not going to kill you but yeah go this
way first there's nowhere to go yeah
wait here while I telepathically
activate this machine what he looks like
a [__] Star Wars like an atst almost
how did that work out no
idea
all right coming up on some
good stuff yeah this this room isn't is
uh it's pretty intense it looks like the
fire temple room from the end of Ocarina
of
Time this is weird
mhm um okay before you go any far I
would pull out your rifle maybe okay eh
never mind hand gun's fine sorry I'm
guiding you way too much okay but yeah
before you go any farther shoot him okay
you get too close that thing starts
spewing fire
[Music]
everywhere oh no it's all right uh you
definitely want to kill him before he go
to far the handout would probably be
best because you don't have to take as
much
time [__] it's a dumb room it's super
dumb he
keeps all right
all right the hand gun would be way
faster than or go up the stairs
[Music]
behind yeah they take one hit all right
cool oh my God is this a jump it's such
a stupid
room so each wait did you pass that
already cuz each dude you kill brings
that up you might have past it pass what
yeah the treasure chest right there
oh I don't I I'm trying to remember if
this room is necessary or not why what
is this elaborate room holding like
$5,000 it's like a Mario level like you
just stumble into Bowser's toilet
um all right nice nice blogging aim
sorry you could just wait at the
platform you don't have to follow the
hole the whole way I'm going to follow
it okay
down
yo
fire damn it have Tak to fire run he
could heal
[Music]
up okay so I need to kill that dude
that's breathing fire on
you
where do you think he
is like right behind this
platform what's going on is that a new
guy yep so I got to kill two of them
now yeah you could stand to heal all
right [__] uh give me a second I got a
lot going on so one dude's right to your
right right now I got it I'm on it all
right so this maybe no maybe I can just
eat a
plant sure
all right here we
go dude your left should be the priority
of to fire breathing dude got it [__] uh
yeah he's sing ah [__] [__] yeah go back
down and come back out isn't there like
a
Dodge all right oh my God heal oh my God
all right it's not not going so
well get out of my
way yeah these guys are going to keep
coming these what yeah
they kill the no
yeah yeah now go up and then kill the
fire breathing got it got
it
no
who [__] I'm having a bad
time
sorry oh [__] uh yeah yeah actually you
know what do
this you what jump to the platform
behind you when you get the chance like
right now maybe you can rifle the dude
from over here the fire breathing dude
cuz he's being a pain he's the main
problem right now oh [__] yeah jump off
to behind you behind you other way other
way other way it's too late no it's not
I'm trapped in this G
way here at this side and then
jump gave me the option pretty late I
think
wait don't just keep running in
circles
okay please please turn around
now jump through the
hole just wait at this platform it will
a button will pop up there you go there
you go thank you now just rifle the dude
over on the dragon or
whatever you should be able to see him
unless he's facing you I've had such a
[__] time I'm sorry oh [__] is he facing
you right now I don't even know if you
can see
him where is he
Do they hide
him they get him he's up that's that's
his thing right
there shoot the oh [__] can you shoot
the chains you might be able to shoot
the chains on the thing I might be an
idiot all right try shooting the chains
above the dragon I'd be so pissed if
this
is an
option it's all
shiny try it a couple like one more time
I feel like if the thing's coming up
then you might be able to do
it should I do it with my good gun
sure why is
this like this
yeah no okay never mind uh I would just
handgun the dude like go fast like you
keep going over there and then when
those two guys come you stop worrying
about the
lava I can't believe this is so
hard I think I'm a little
rusty he's going
to [__]
I a damn
it
[__] stop killing me yeah don't worry
about okay go behind there got it don't
worry about these two dudes yet just
kill this guy right
now he got him all right now I'll kill
these two dudes or actually I don't even
know don't worry about that yet these
two dudes are going to keep coming like
this group of guys so try to kill this
guy go how do I kill him have to you
just have to he's going to be aiming
over here so now go to the other side
and shoot him oh okay got it we got to
go past this wall yeah right there to
like here yep I mean he faster you might
have to be able go
faster I don't even know if this room is
worth it anymore not the way I'm
playing
[__] there's not enough petas in the
world
yeah this dude's a pain it doesn't help
that you're limping slower you could
just heal
anyway I got it I got it I got it yeah
you didn't give enough time to go over
to that side there you go
like I think you should heal up all
right you'll be way
faster saying all right but
all I'm having a bad day now wait for
him to come over this way he's in the
middle still got it okay now go yeah
might not have given him long
enough [__] now go to the other side
what this part
sucks I got your arm oh God I did
it I asked Mike like how much longer I
had until I finished it and he was like
if you play really good like 8
hours so let's amend that and make it
nine um oh you didn't need to come here
okay that's it's one of the
pieces all right what am I doing now
going
back that platform that's nowhere near
compated yeah get that should be like
5,000 good oh
nice I think you can just sell that out
right I don't get attached
cool so unnecessary all these
elaborate jump I got it I got it I got
it are you doing this on purpose to
torture me cuz it's working just
[__] all right there you
go I like don't see it the world the way
you do
what that wasn't as
obvious so I think you have two of the
items now let's go back onto
this steampunk machine of sexual doesn't
make how is it sexy how is it sex like
you just said you see the world
differently than I do um ah gotcha save
cuz I don't want to see that all
again
[Music]
cool here we
go on do another machine that makes no
sense is she getting on too or
yep she's like this is nice it's a nice
break I like not having to do anything
oh God here we go
okay there's things to your
left oh get away from me
snake okay oh nice two shotgun shells
nope Spinelli and a shotgun shell it's
like they felt bad for me for doing so
badly y they're like put some vases in
there God bless
her
um
uh put the things in behind you this is
like the first room of the castle
remember this whole thing
happened
no this is when like what's his name
went behind this
door this was a while
ago I don't goat lion
Snake
Man Leon's the lion this is just a snake
butt
[Music]
yep
okay oh there's Secret Stairs over
there let's get out the old trusty
map so let's go up those
stairs what is
this
yes I learned that from
you get away from me
Ashley yes
FR anything
else
yeah it's just a actually that might be
one of the other things you put into the
crown that would be cool I don't know
how to get down there though that's
where you just came from oh gotcha
gotcha of course of course right it's
all making sense I understand though
this this the level design is revealing
itself jeez all right here we go why you
just walk into a corner are you oh you
looking at the screen over I was looking
at the recording and making sure the
audio is recording we had a lot of
technical problems this morning they're
all fine now thanks to Eric
[Music]
Tay think you get one more Gem and then
you put it into forget what you we might
have missed that I have no idea honestly
all right so I'm just going straight
here
mhm another another ride look how many
other parts to this Castle there are
this thing is [__] huge
like looks like three Hogs pushed
together those are our Rich
Neighbors when I become rich I'm going
to have one of
these just like um just shuttle you
between your houses yeah um but like in
the movie movie Casper it'll have that
thing that helps me get ready in the
morning and it'll like wash my hair and
brush my teeth so I can like kind of be
like asleep during the whole thing and
it'll like put a comb through my hair
it's a weird
reference no it's how feel I shouldn't
be talking I do those all the time
that's correct face
off right what oh the movie face off
yeah okay so oh
right uh don't go there yet you there's
like two other ways to go that you
didn't go yet um that's correct but I
chose one of them yeah you went the
wrong way there's a merchant right
behind you this way nope in this door
no there there's a door right there
that's the
merchant there a lot there was a lot
going on
there look at me just robbing this
Merchant might have new stuff for you
[Music]
welcome got some rare things on sale
stranger all right what are you selling
he doesn't seem like he has anything
new all right so I have a broken
butterfly keep that though yeah sell
those this stuff uh this elegant perfume
bottle yeah are you sure mhm
[Music]
okay uh illuminat
pendant that and the butterf lamp sell
the Velvet Blues okay is that all
strange is that
all thank anything new tune up some of
your favorite weapons it didn't have any
um what do you buy
in yeah see I don't get that um okay
might as
well
uh I got the
money Firepower I would not worry about
cuz that's already pretty yeah uh reload
speed is that all
stranger I'm literally thinking whether
these are worth it because of a specific
fight that you us again H yeah sure
Capac is that all
strength thank you but I have why is
this red you don't have that gun anymore
that's a regular shotgun red um
some see if you you can do the Ron
first oh no you can't never mind okay
cool is that all strange is that all
strange is that all strange
come back any time cool oh I'm going to
save him as
[Music]
well
cool all right which door should I go in
there's a [__] ton of them worry about
the firing
range
um okay so go right that way to the
right yeah this way okay so up into the
right flashbangs are going to come in
[Music]
handy aliens look at this dude that's a
[__]
alien that is great res 4 great video G
somebody made the head good friend of
mine great video game somebody put the
face on later yep res Evil 4 great video
game excellent pacing okay
sad
his
potato head is just morphed someone did
have to photoshop something on theree it
up and then what's
that what's
that some bad
paintings it's creepy that looks like
a you probably use that with a green
right now if you want
to nope never mind you don't have
anything to combine it with yeah I
do
oh I would wait on that
okay oh there's a piece of paper o piece
of
paper uhoh I looks like they want him
dead that's so [__] stupid
like um sample is back where it
Longs
uh
uh we shall capture Ashley and take her
to the Lord and dispose the American
agent okay moving
on there's some ammo in that Lion's
butt it's a weird place for a butt but
I'll take it there we go
oh listen you have
wait yeah yeah I I don't think it
matters but just to be safe I guess wait
sure like that guy is twitching yeah
just get ready for some quick times son
are you sure I can't like I mean I don't
think so you might be able to
but that guy looks like he's ready to
pounce
that rosta thing I didn't do a good job
on that one press R1 I did press R1 and
[Music]
L1 follow
me is she still good to follow yep that
looks important
mhm shotgun ammo over
there anything else free that I should
take before this [__] fight happens
other side there's a green herb over
there to your
right
yep all right
Ashley stay
down
here we
go oh no they have helmets I would pull
your shotgun out okay and
then
[Music]
okay oh head what she's almost
dead
now don't that's why the flashbang com
got it so take off all their helmets and
flashbang them all yeah that's the ideal
situation but I mean if you're going to
die
like yeah okay Ashley's going to
die I don't think I can I guess I guess
just throw a flashbang at him right now
just to get rid of two at
least they're coming toward you I don't
think they're going to go toward Ashley
so you should
be uh she should come towards you now
hopefully shotgun
oh
go oh okay sorry we're
[Music]
good heal her
okay
jeez that was a close one wasn't it
Ashley oh [__] you got to reload your
[Music]
shot yeah have her like wait over this
so they won't steal her
y oh [__] super slow they're not that
hard I'm the one in danger you stupid
[__]
[Music]
yes damn that is a wide
radius only if you throw it
perfectly are you trying to take credit
for something the game just
did oh [__] I
missed [__] I got it I got
it been playing a lot of Neo lately they
kind of remind me of these terracotta
things that come you really like Neo
don't you good
cool that was um not very
far
uh I don't think it's as pretty as I
thought it would be like the lighting is
strange or something I had to turn like
the brightest up on my TV me
too um it's supposed to be dark at some
parts though follow me but I like the
idea of it like I like the idea that um
every piece you collect changes some
kind of uh part of you right like like
your speed or your like dodging ability
or your attack with a melee or whatever
like it's cool that you get that many
options yeah it's like a loot Fest mixed
with dark souls you got that gr right
yeah you did you're going way oh wait
there is another door you can go through
hold on I thought let me pull out the
map no never mind good thing I have a
map all right so we're
going back I don't see
any quick time
events I'm going to
save
you got a checkpoint I think you don't
are you sure okay um where am I going
this way try left I don't think you can
go left yet but try
it here
y all right go here all
right
oh
wait okay there's four of
those got it I'm on
it does that count
yep w yeah good as well be
perfect now does
it okay just works permanently now yeah
I'd have her follow
you I think you've lived long enough
enough let's see if you can survive is
he wearing this time sandals probably
he's a weird little
dude
uh all right shoot those red things just
like I don't want you to die these
yep just four of
them
I don't want to guide you too much but I
also didn't want you to die if we didn't
save couldn't I just run through here I
don't think it was
open actually I don't know um is there
something you can grab in here
though there you
go that was such a weird scene yep why
didn't I just shoot him I don't know
where's the drama in that I don't know
you know um remember how I was like why
don't to just shoot that guy before he
gets to the machine gun yep um someone
in the uh comment said you can yeah you
can like totally just kill him and and
avoid that entire but where's the drama
that forgot how much we love drama
uh where did they get that drilling
machine so am I shooting these guys I
assume I should get my good gun
huh
simple come through stupid Ashley
buka wait follow me all right where am I
going it's weird that killing them opens
the door but it doesn't stop the machine
mhm I agree doesn't really make any
sense there's a few more things I think
in here to behind you
okay the
barrels oh right or a
[Music]
barrel just totally missed some free
potas um oh
oh
elegant so elegant you almost missed a
lot I I really did you know I honestly
think I've seen these before and I've
missed them I need to pay more attention
to like things that look like they could
be
open
hello oh we're just back
yep okay to that door you got the
Queen's girl and the King's girl no
other door to your right got it totally
and then the left
okay
clear
oh wait look up can you you just n them
probably yeah it's not clear at
all Ashley it's not
clear look at all those spinellis mhm
all right so kill first Spinelli later
mhm do you think I can throw this
properly just lure them this way just
walk
out are is done sing one at a time oh my
God shoot the rest I
guess
die Nazi
scum I think you could you could on par
these guys with Nazis yeah you're
forgetting those what spinellis oh right
the spinellis I think that's what they
are you think this would Dam damage the
item to dropping in a dirty
well I remember that that seems like a
while ago uh well technically it never
happened cuz we redid that
episode so no oh wait did you just get
the green gem I think I did I don't know
if you have the thing you could put
those in yet I think it's a crown but
you could try uh let me
see those are no those aren't these are
just what they are yeah um so I have
have you don't have that you need the
red thing for that okay blue sorry so
you have all three of those but you just
need the thing you put them in what is
it it's a crown I think so you don't
have it yet hopefully I didn't miss it
no I don't think you did you'll be
fine this looks like I put the cups in
there
mhm
cups cups Cups cups Cups cups
Cups CS CS CS
CSS first try making
progress out of the way
vonka I'm afraid of killing her with my
knife
now
she's like way
too Jesus Christ well stand there just
go [__] it no don't waste it don't don't
this is
personal [__]
yeah
[__] all right you live this
time I have been missing these I have
not been all open though you were just
at a couple that didn't open
I don't think I've been doing a good job
whatever yeah this one doesn't
open [__]
snake hello is anyone there oh this
place looks like
[__] uh I feel like shoot the chains on
that thing that is alive don't move yet
like don't go forward shoot the chains
on the thing do your left
oh it's like a big
uula I don't know what that is with
strep throat all right where am I going
shoot those chains got it yeah totally
you got to shoot the actual thing where
they connect I think
oh out of range you're not even aiming
at it I know
whatever it's a
b
Dam
it Ashley who could have predicted
bugman great more of
them
gross shotg got it oh
Lord okay
[__] you stop vomiting on me
rude [__] there's so many of them and
they have a lot of
vomit [__]
upow now jeez
there's just
so
[__] there's like too many of
them
no this is [__] you're just like
throwing everything you learned out the
window you walk like 5T and then turned
around to shoot him yes you already have
a green I need a
blue man should I use it yeah
doing a bad job there's still a dude up
there I think I see him little [__]
he's going to
die so all right I got multi
now you need a red sorry a I got so
excited go get plenty of them all
right
all
right okay that's what I
[Music]
needed I said drop
down
well I
hope having a really tiny amount of
health is enough jeez can I like burn
that or something no there's a dude up
there wait hold on shoot that bug up
there maybe he'll give you a red there's
a
couple a it's hitting the thing you
know you know yeah he
knows [__]
[Music]
you all right is that it think so what's
your right behind you right right there
is there anything over
there Oh you mean like on this yeah no
you're good
no
jeez unsuccessful bug
land successful for the bugs he
is don't don't do that to me [__] you
can sell welcome I still didn't get a
[__] red though got some rare things
on sale stranger what are you
selling uh chest board yeah
ah purple gem thank you no none of the
gems uh the green eye both those is that
all
stranger thank you is that all spell
thank you is that
all thank you what are you
buying some stuff you can tune up I
think is is that all
strange you don't even you're doing that
just
to piss me off thank you what are you
buying
yeah is that all
stranger is that all
stranger thank
you so now don't worry about that yet I
wouldn't I wouldn't worry about
that wait did you even check anything
else time no I forgot yeah you just
backed out without thinking about it
didn't you I don't know what you buying
there you go right
gun is that all
strange thank you is that all
strange thank you
cool all right it's pretty good mhm not
bad not bad not bad um great we can go
like to another typewriter we can do
another episode we can do another
episode but okay cool sure sweet
you're getting toward the end of the
castle yes sort of it's just me and my
best friend walking along in a
castle I love him too the end it's just
me my best
friend I'm in his
mask stop
that look at him in his Dead
Eye